la vidéo d'aujourd'hui fait suite aux
trois dernières vidéos ou n'introduit
les tests randomisée en double aveugle
et la paix value euna lee ses cinq
sacres et travers de la science par p
value est juste pour rappel même si la
paix value a énormément contribué à
améliorer la validité des sciences elle
est néanmoins très imparfaite
en particulier on a vu que la science
par p value finit par réfuté infiniment
souvent toute hypothèse vrai interdit
l'arrêt prématuré des tests subis le
biais de publications des résultats
statistiquement significatifs et
davantage surprenant permet le pea king
et repose sur une énorme malléabilité
qui la rend beaucoup plus subjective
qu'il n'y paraît ça fait déjà pas mal de
travers et pourtant ce sont loin d'être
les plus gros travers de la science par
p value aujourd'hui on va ajouter cinq
énormes travers pour accabler encore un
peu plus cette méthode scientifique
énorme travers numéro
tout focaliser sur l'existence d'un
effet en pratique malheureusement les
débats tournent souvent autour de la
question est-ce que x cause y notamment
quand il s'agit de politique ou de
justice mais aussi de médecine
d'économie ou d'environnement où on a
tendance à partir à la chasse à un
coupable ou du moins à la chasse un
responsable et ce qui est gênant c'est
qu'avec la méthode scientifique par p
value on est prêt à répondre oui x cause
y
même si l'effet de x / y est en fait
très petit en effet la science par
prévalu
ça ne consiste pas tant à mesurer
l'effet probable de x / y ça consiste
davantage à rejeter l'hypothèse à 0 qui
dit que x n'a aucun effet sur y
alors bien sûr on peut et il faut
rajouter une discussion de l'ampleur de
x / y si jamais on rejette h 0 et il y a
plusieurs métriques pour ce faire comme
l'expliquent très bien risque alpha
cependant il reste qu'un travers
récurrents semble être l'attention
démesurée porté sur l'existence d'un
effet ou non par exemple voici les
conclusions de différentes agences sur
les effets cancérigènes du glyphosate
aux doses usuelles on y voit plein de
phrase alambiquée qui parle d'un effet
avec un niveau de preuve
insuffisant ou qu'il est peu probable
qu'il y ait un effet potentiel et ainsi
de suite
le premier avec ses formulations c'est
qu'elle donne l'impression qu' étant
données les données actuelles il serait
prématuré de conclure quoi que ce soit à
propos du glyphosate
pourtant on a collecté pas mal de
données au fil des dernières années sur
le glyphosate
il semble que l'on puisse dire quelque
chose de manière plus affirmative et
bien l'astuce pour y arriver c'est tout
simplement de dire aux f
à la question est ce que le glyphosate
un effet car si je devais parier je
parierais en taxant flipper qu'il a un
effet mais la question pertinente en
pratique n'est pas de savoir s'il a un
effet la question pertinente c'est de
savoir quelle est l'ampleur de cet effet
hélas si vous regardez un peu les
chiffres ici tiré du blog de sens
étonnante sans même sortir l'artillerie
lourde du bail à nice mme il ya quelque
chose qui saute aux yeux
tout est fait du glyphosate semble être
nécessairement très négligeable les
chiffres indiquent même que tout effet
cancérigène du glyphosate est quasi
sûrement extrêmement négligeable comparé
à de nombreux autres produits
cancérigènes de notre quotidien comme le
tabac l'alcool ou même l'excellent de
viande rouge
il me semble que c'est ça l'information
importante qui aurait dû sortir des
études l'existence d'un effet importe
finalement
ce qui est crucial pour les prises de
décision ce sont davantage les tailles
des faits probable or dans le cas du
glyphosate
on peut clairement dire que beaucoup
d'autres produits cancérigènes devrait
être beaucoup plus préoccupant que le
glyphosate y compris des produits en
fait assez peu cancérigènes je ferai
d'ailleurs la même remarque pour la
vidéo d'hygiène mentale sur l'effet de
la lune sur les naissances
cette vidéo est vraiment super mais la
conclusion bayésienne ne peut pas être
qui n'existe aucun effet de la lune sur
les naissances la conclusion bayésienne
intéressante en tout cas c'est surtout
que tout est fait de la lune sur les
naissances est nécessairement très
largement imperceptible et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raison qu'il est
intéressant d'avoir des très grands
échantillons oui parce qu'une étude avec
une plus value de 1 % pour un
échantillon de 1 million de données
c'est en fait bien souvent surtout une
étude qui montre que l'effet est minime
certes avec une plus value de 1 % un
effet statistiquement significatifs a
techniquement été identifié et je mets
des normes guimet sur statistiquement
significatif si vous ne les avez pas vu
mais cet effet est alors potentiellement
si imperceptible qu'il est alors
possiblement plus judicieux de faire
comme s'il n'existait pas
malheureusement en donnant trop
d'importance au rejet d'hypothèses nul
la science par p va lui semble détourner
notre attention vers des questions très
secondaire comme l'existence ou non d'un
effet quelle que soit sa taille énorme
travers numéro 2
les données en laboratoire ne sont pas
toujours généralisable très souvent
quand on parle de science pour savoir
nous invite gentiment effectué un test
randomisée en double aveugle et ça c'est
super bizarre quand vous y réfléchissez
oui parce que bien souvent les questions
qui nous intéresse vraiment concernent
des choses de la vraie vie typiquement
des comportements dans leur habitat
naturel avec leur environnement usuelles
sauf que pour tester des hypothèses sur
ces comportements on nous invite à
extraire des particules ou les individus
de leur habitat habituelles et à les
mettre dans des laboratoires où on les
confronte à des expériences hors du
commun
dire que cela devrait être fin mot sur
le comportement réel des individus sa
part être être un non sens alors je dis
bien sûr pas que les tests randomisée en
double aveugle n'ont aucune valeur mais
vu à quel point ils correspondent à des
contextes différents des contextes qui
nous intéresse vraiment il ya vraiment
de quoi être dubitatif sur le fait que
ces tests nous fournirons une réponse
définitive ou même simplement une
réponse plus valides aux questions que
l'on se pose vraiment pire encore les
tests en laboratoire sont parfois très
distant des conditions réelles
d'application de tel ou tel traitement
typiquement les tests cliniques de
médicaments sont souvent effectués sur
des individus disons de 30 ans en bonne
santé alors que parfois ils seront
davantage prescrits à des femmes âgées
et malades
la généralise à militer des tests
cliniques est alors questionnable non
seulement en termes d'efficacité du
traitement mais aussi et surtout en
terme d'absence d'effets secondaires car
a priori une personne en bonne santé
aura beaucoup moins de chances de
développer des effets secondaires qu'une
personne âgée et malade
de la même manière la plupart des
expériences de psychologie sont
restreintes à des individus dit woods
c'est à dire western éducative endpoint
rich and democratic control la
généralise à militer des résultats de
ces expériences à la population mondiale
est très questionnable et sa
généralisable itea individu en
particulier de la population mondiale
il est encore plus surtout si cet
individu n'est pas lui-même weird
et oui parce que les questions vraiment
pertinente en pratique ce n'est pas
ainsi en moyenne sur la population
mondiale l'hypothèse h 0 est vrai bien
souvent notamment quand il s'agit de
traitements médicaux la question
vraiment pertinente c est ce qu un
individu donné avec ses traits
physiologiques et sa génétique très
particulière est-ce que cet individu a
de bonnes chances de profiter de tel ou
tel traitement voire est-il désirable de
lui prescrire tellement
gamin qui est encore une autre question
or malheureusement en cherchant des
effets statistiques valide pour des très
grands échantillons le fréquentent is ne
nous invite pas à nous poser de telles
questions
le fréquentent isme va souvent davantage
s'intéresser à des effets moyen sur
toute une population et du coup ses
réponses seront très incomplète quand il
s'agit de cas particuliers bref encore
une fois je ne dis pas tout ça pour
complètement rejeté les tests randomisée
en double aveugle
ces tests fournissent des données de
qualité cependant il me semble qu'il
serait très fallacieux de considérer que
ces tests répondre vraiment aux
questions intéressantes des sciences en
particulier certains statisticiens pense
qu'il est temps de cesser d'y voir le
standard ultime des sciences tout ça
parce que les tests randomisée en double
aveugle soudan fait est très loin d'être
clairement généralisable à l'instar des
données obtenues autrement que via des
tests randomisés les données issues de
la méthode scientifique doivent
absolument être pris avec des pincettes
et être analysées avec soin et pour ne
pas faire d'erreur dans cette analyse
il semble nécessaire d'introduire un
cadre de pensée qui transcende largement
le cadre très restreint du test
statistique classique et non travers
numéro 3
[Musique]
que faire quand tout est rejetée
on a déjà vu que toute hypothèse vrai
finira par être rejetée une infinité de
fois par la science par p value mais en
pratique l'application rigoureuse de la
méthode scientifique par p va lui devra
être bien plus problématique que ça
surtout dès lors que l'on étudie des
systèmes complexes comme la
macroéconomie l'environnement le cerveau
humain internet ou unia qui fait du
diplôme ning pour tous ces systèmes
toute hypothèse non trivial qu on
avancerait est quasiment assuré d'être
fausse oui parce qu'il semble illusoire
d'espérer capturer toute la complexité
de ces systèmes
en une poignée d' hypothèse ces systèmes
sont fondamentalement complexe leur
description rigoureuse semblent
nécessairement complexe voire
inaccessible et en fait quand on étudie
ces systèmes on ne cherche pas
nécessairement les théories vrai on
cherche généralement davantage et les
théories simplificatrice qui colle
néanmoins assez bien avec le système
qu'on étudie et donc en particulier
c'est en fait très bien que les
hypothèses nécessaire à l'efficience des
marchés ou au théorème de vollmann
morgenstern ou à la mécanique classique
sont en fait fausse on les a rejetés
réfuté détruites tout ce que vous voulez
et pourtant on continue de les enseigner
et de les utiliser pour développer des
théories scientifiques
est ce que les scientifiques marche sur
leur tête en fait c'est plutôt la
science par p value et plus généralement
la science par réfutabilité et
réfutation qui me semble à côté de la
plaque
oui quand on fait de la macroéconomie on
finira par rejeter toute théorie simple
mais à quoi bon
qu'est-ce qu'on fait une fois qu'on a
rejeté toutes les théories le truc c'est
que souvent une règle simple mais pas
trop fort reste très utile et très
désirable à mettre en avant en sciences
on peut prendre l'exemple des lois de la
gravité de newton
ces lois ont été rejetées depuis belle
lurette elle était en effet incapable
d'expliquer la trajectoire de mercure y
compris avant l'avènement de la
relativité générale d'einstein
cependant on a longtemps refusé de
rejeter les lois de newton
non pas parce que toutes les données
coller avec ses merveilleuses loi mais
tout simplement parce qu'il semblait
impossible de concevoir des alternatives
un tant soit peu crédibles les théories
peuvent en fait survivre pourvu qu
aucune alternative crédible n'ait été
proposée
plus généralement il semble en fait
extrêmement fallacieux de voir la
science comme une suite de procès qui
jugent et condamnent les mauvaises
théorie il semble davantage que la
science consiste en une forêt de modèles
dont certains arbres sont parfois taille
et parfois même coupé mais cette forêt
n'est généralement pas composée d'un
seul arbre et qui plus est l'arbre qui
suit
longue de toute la forêt n'est pas
nécessairement celui qui a raison ce
sera plutôt l'art qui aura été le moins
écorché mais ce n'est pas tout la
science est faite est exploité par des
humains et l'humain à les limites
cognitives qui là et même quand la
science est faite par des machines ces
machines ont elles aussi leurs limites
algorithmique et du coup en pratique
notamment pour l'étude de systèmes
complexes
une solution simple et approximative
sera préférable à une solution dont le
temps de calcul nécessitent par exemple
toute la consommation de tout l'exercice
du système solaire en pratique il nous
faut des modèles faciles à manipuler
algorithmique mans et ce même s'ils sont
moins crédible que des alternatives et
sa tv quand c'est le cas des lois de
newton qui même si elles sont moins
crédible que la relativité générale
elles ont le bon goût d'être beaucoup
plus simple à manipuler algorithmique
mans et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
souvent très mal compris par la science
par réfutation de façon générale a
priori l'application rigoureuse de la
science par réfutation n'a rien à faire
de la simplicité des calculs si c'est
faux a priori on a envie de réfuter et
du coup si on suivait vraiment cette
méthode scientifique il nous faudrait
taire tous ceux qui osent encore parler
des lois de newton
tout comme on cherche à taire tous ceux
qui pensent que la terre est plate
énorme travers numérique
toutes les hypothèses ne se valent pas a
priori
voilà un principe qui est souvent mise
en avant par les et éthicien notamment à
travers le rasoir d'occam aussi appelé
principe de parcimonie
en gros ce rasoir d'occam dit que les
théories plus simples sont plus
crédibles
a priori et intuitivement c'est pour ça
que les scientifiques rejette
généralement les théories à base d'
alien bon en fait l'application du
rasoir d'occam en pratique est quasiment
toujours extrêmement bancal et pire que
c'est la possibilité de l'utiliser a
tendance à augmenter la malléabilité de
méthodes scientifiques dont on a parlé
la dernière fois et a encouragé le
raisonnement inconsciemment motivé on
reviendra d'ailleurs bien plus
longuement et plus attentivement sur ce
rasoir d'occam plus tard dans cette
série sur la forme le pays est en fait
en pratique en sciences ce n'est
généralement pas ce rasoir d'occam qui
permet de distinguer les théories a
priori typiquement sur la possibilité
d'une machine à moteur perpétuelle tout
physicien aura un préjugé très prononcé
mais aussi très justifiée étant donné
l'état des connaissances actuelles de la
physique
il faudrait violé des lois physiques
très très très établies pour concevoir
une machine à moteur perpétuelle or la
crédence du physicien notamment les lois
de la thermodynamique à notre échelle
est absolument énorme
en fait cette créance est si énorme que
même la démonstration la plus
convaincante qu'il soit aura bien du mal
à déplacer le curseur de crédence du
physicien vers une crédence non
négligeable en la possibilité d'une
machine à moteur perpétuelle de la même
façon je serais extrêmement sceptique à
l'idée qu'une machine physique surpasse
les facultés algorithmique d'une machine
de turing universel l'histoire de
l'algorithmique approché mon curseur de
crédence très loin en faveur de l'as dit
't'es de church turing et il faudra des
éléments à charge bien plus convaincant
qu'un test randomisés ap valu à 5,6 main
pour ramener ce curseur au point que je
me mette à assigner une crédence non
négligeable au fait que la thèse de
church turing est fausse comme le dira
monsieur fille qui paraphrase carl sagan
des affirmations extraordinaire au caire
tes preuves plus qu'ordinaire et ça ça
s'applique particulièrement bien à tant
de sujets à si chère à la zététique la
lune n'a probablement pas d'effet majeur
sur la naissance du cardia les forces de
marée car les forces de marées causés
par vos toilettes sont plusieurs ordres
de grandeur plus important que celle de
la lune de même l'homéopathie n'a quasi
sûrement aucun effet au-delà dû placer
vos car la physique et la chimie moderne
ou bien identifier l'ensemble des
particules qui ont des effets non
négligeables dans notre quotidien et on
comprend suffisamment bien la biologie
pour affirmer avec une
énorme cadence que tout effet des
particules présentes dans un cachet
d'homéopathie sera très largement
moindre qu'une modification même un film
disons des habitudes alimentaires
malheureusement la méthode scientifique
et du coup souvent les scientifiques et
les vulgarisateurs scientifiques ont
tendance à insister davantage sur les
tests randomisée en double aveugle que
sur ce genre de considérations
théoriques
alors que ces considérations théoriques
ont pourtant bien plus d'incidence dans
le raisonnement bayésiens en tout cas
dans le cas des théories incompatible
avec les lois les plus crédibles de la
physique
pire encore certains encouragent parfois
tout le monde à suspendre son jugement
et à attendre les résultats du test
randomisés pour conclure sans prendre en
compte aucun a priori
voilà qui semble fallacieux et on
reparlera d'ailleurs davantage la
prochaine fois en particulier en
pratique ceci a conduit à autoriser les
tests cliniques pour de nombreux
médicaments dont on pouvait légitimement
douter qu'ils avaient un effet
quelconque et parce que les tests clips
sont encore autorités beaucoup de ces
médicaments sont effectivement tester il
faut alors s'attendre à ce que 5 %
d'entre eux soit alors validé voilà qui
selon le philosophe jacob steak and gas
a conduit à la commercialisation d'un
très grand nombre de médicaments dont
les effets sont probablement très
largement moindre que disons une petite
habitude sportive additionnel chez les
patients énorme travers numéro 5
que faire de ceux qui ne se prête pas au
p va lieu enfin et surtout comme on l'a
déjà évoqué à de nombreuses reprises
le plus gros problème de la paix value
il me semble c'est de constamment tourné
notre attention vers ce qui peut être
mesuré via une plus value comme le dira
à brad may sauf quand tout ce que l'on a
est un marteau tour semble alors un clou
alors si tout était effectivement un
clou ce ne serait pas dérangeant mais
malheureusement beaucoup de questions
sans doute même l'écrasante majorité des
questions dignes d'intérêt ne se prête
tout simplement pas à la paix value
c'est le cas par exemple des études du
passé qui analyse des vestiges qui ne se
prêtent clairement pas au test
randomisés comme en histoire en
archéologie en anthropologie en
paléontologie en géologie en phylogénie
en psychologie évolutionnaire en
astrophysique ou encore en cosmologie
dans tous ces cas la paix value n'est
quasiment jamais applicable directement
il faut alors tendre le cou à ces
sciences pour ordonner des airs de tests
par p value voire pire encore les
ramener à des questions qui ne sont en
fait pas les questions dignes d'intérêt
mais ce problème n'est pas spécifique
aux séances du passé il s'agit également
d'un problème pour les analyses du
présent qui étudient des comportements
ou des phénomènes spécifiques l état
actuel de l'univers comme en sociologie
en économie en psychologie en sciences
politiques en études des réseaux en full
aux copies en études des écosystèmes ou
encore en météorologie
enfin et surtout ce problème était
également un problème pour les
prédictions sur le futur qu'il s'agisse
de prédiction autour du climat à venir
des ressources naturelles qui finiront
par manquer des technologies à venir des
conséquences de la polarisation des
tensions géopolitiques et des risques de
catastrophe majeure
et puis à celle ci on ne peut bien sûr
ajouter tous les domaines fondamentaux
qu'on associe généralement à la
philosophie comme l'épistémologie la
morale des trucs plus bizarre encore
comme les mathématiques ou
l'algorithmique le réflexe d'un
scientifique conditionnée à raisonner en
termes de réfutabilité de tests
randomisée et de réfutation part prévalu
c'est souvent de rejeter la
scientificité de ces questions voire de
les qualifier de pseudo science selon ce
scientifique
en un sens il s'agit là de questions qui
ne sont pas aux standards de la science
et je trouve ça personnellement
extrêmement étrange est très
insatisfaisant
c'est comme si la science se refusait de
se poser certaines questions uniquement
parce que ces questions ne ressemblait
pas suffisamment un des clous or à en
croire les adeptes du mob se aux
sciences
la science ne s'autorise qu'à taper sur
des clous avec son marteau et du coup le
mieux que la science puisse faire c'est
taper sur ce qui ressemble à peu près un
cloud ou déformée certaines questions
suffisamment pour qu'elle se met à
ressembler à un clou autrement dit le
préjugé des scientifiques sur ce qu'est
la science semble les avoir conduits à
délimiter un ensemble de questions qu'il
qualifie de scientifiques et a considéré
que les autres ne mérite même pas leur
attention voire à les dénigrer en les
qualifiant haut tellement de pseudo
science il me semble qu'il s'agit
vraiment là du plus énormes et du plus
grave des travers de la science comme le
disait le statisticien gionta qui mieux
vaut une réponse approximative à la
bonne question qui est souvent vagues
plutôt qu'une réponse exacte à la
mauvaise question qui peut toujours être
rendu précise il me semble grand temps
de questionner les questions que
s'autorisent les sciences car les
questions vraiment importantes se
doivent d'être adressée avec rigueur y
compris lorsqu'elles ne sont pas
conformes au cadre rigide des sciences
par réfutation via l'expérience
j'espère que les dernières vidéos vous
auront vraiment donné beaucoup de grain
à moudre
il vous fera réfléchir sur la science la
méthode scientifique et peut-être
surtout sur l'objectif des sciences il
me semble que trop souvent on veut fixer
un cadre trop rigide pour la méthode
scientifique bien avant de se poser la
question de l'objectif de cette méthode
scientifique ou alors on se contente
d'un objectif qui à bien y réfléchir est
vraiment étrange
par exemple rejeté les théories fausses
newton lavoisier et darwin ont-ils
vraiment fait cela ont ils vraiment
cherché à rejeter des théories fausses
et leur propre théorie était elle fausse
mais surtout la fausseté de leurs
théories et elle ce qu'il est adéquat de
retenir de leurs travaux malheureusement
il me semble qu'on croise dans la
science à un certain cadre rigide on
restreint drastiquement le champ
d'application et et de la science ou du
moins si le mot aux sciences vous
dérange
disons de la pensée rigoureuse le 21e
siècle annonce toutes sortes de défis
majeurs de l'économie à l'environnement
en passant par la santé les tensions
politiques et l'intelligence
artificielle sans pensée rigoureuse
capable de traiter tous ces sujets il me
semble très probable qu'on en vienne à
penser ces problèmes de travers et qu'on
dépense nos ressources de manière
contreproductive
alors je précise tout de même que ce que
j'entends ici par pensée rigoureuse
n'est absolument pas tout et n'importe
quoi bien réfléchir à comment bien
réfléchir est un défi monumental
extrêmement difficile et si vous n'y
avez pas déjà très longuement réfléchi
alors vous avez très certainement encore
beaucoup à apprendre par exemple au
hasard en regardant les excellents vidéo
de jules agalev bien réfléchir c'est
très difficile bien pensé c'est
compliqué
néanmoins dans le monde moderne ultra
complexes ça semble être devenu urgent
il nous faut absolument beaucoup plus
réfléchir à comment mieux réfléchir et
pour le coup c'est sans doute la
question la plus fascinante qui soit
comment bien réfléchir en particulier me
semble que la pensée rigoureuse doit
absolument se donner les moyens de mieux
comprendre les phénomènes de notre
environnement moderne et ça ça semble
nécessité de transcender le cadre rigide
de la méthode scientifique
habituellement présenté d'ailleurs fois
que j'avais déjà listé 5 à travers de la
méthode scientifique par p value et
notamment le pea king entre mme badache
fait remarquer qu' on pourra éviter le
pea king en demandant aux chercheurs de
rapporter tout ce qu'ils ont fait dans
leur étude
cependant ça rendrait les articles de
recherche incroyablement chiant à lire
et incroyablement peu informatifs
puisque la quasi totalité de ce qui se
passe dans un laboratoire de recherche
est bien souvent un ensemble d'échecs
ensemble de trucs qui marchent au pas du
tout qu'on a essayé on a foiré on a raté
quelque chose ça serait en plus très
embarrassant pour les chercheurs
eux-mêmes et typiquement moi
personnellement j'ai une phobie énorme à
l'idée que mes brouillons de
mathématiques soit exposée au grand
public ou soit juste vu par d'autres
mathématiciens parce que ce que j'écris
dans les brouillons et souvent
absolument ridiculement stupide et du
coup en particulier c'est finalement
quelque chose d'assez souhaitable
d'essayer de nettoyer un petit peu
l'histoire de notre recherche d'enlever
tous ceux qui vraiment ne sert à rien
n'est pas instructif et peut-être pour
le coup très embarrassant d'une certaine
manière il faut extraire de ce qui s'est
passé dans le laboratoire de recherche
les parties les plus intéressantes de la
recherche qui s'y est fait ça c'est un
travail extrêmement difficile qui
requiert souvent beaucoup d' expertise
mais également d'avoir été présent sur
les lieux
et du coup a privé c'est aux chercheurs
de faire ça semble difficile d'imaginer
que quelqu'un d'autre puisse faire cela
et du coup le chercheur va devoir
sélectionner les parties de sa recherche
qui sont les plus intéressantes pour les
mettre dans un article de recherche
le problème c'est que ce faisant il peut
être victime d'un pea king qui est
potentiellement inconscient en fait je
dirais même très clairement ce faisant
il fera un pea king très inconscient
bref tout ça pour dire que oui les
chercheurs font duper hacking et c'est
pas bien et tout ça mais c'est
extrêmement difficile de corriger ça en
pratique parce que il faut vraiment
comprendre toute la mécanique de tous si
c'est du passé et à quel point on a fait
un fait acquis nos moments de rapporter
ses résultats ce qui en plus est contre
les incitatifs individuel donc résoudre
le prime du paquis vraiment un problème
très difficile et on peut enfin c'est
pas spécifique au prince de la paix
value
c'est vraiment un problème très
difficile de la sélection de ce qui est
intéressant qui d'ailleurs transcende
également de loin le problème de la
recherche de façon générale quand on
rapporte des choses qui sont passés
un événement ont fait une sélection des
données on a un biais de sélection et ce
biais de sélection peut amener les gens
à conclure des choses qui ne
correspondent pas à ce qu'ils auraient
conclu en étudiant attentivement tout ce
qui s'est passé dans les événements en
question
patience évoque une façon de
partiellement remédier au problème qui
est la solution de ce qu'on appelle les
prix registration en français ça
donnerait quelque chose comme
préinscription et j'imagine l'idée c'est
d'annoncer l'expérience le protocole que
l'on va suivre avant d'effectuer
l'expérience est en effet c'est une
approche qui augmenterait grandement la
transparence de des études scientifiques
et pouvoir réduire le plat du pied à kim
et comme si quelque chose qui n'existe
pas du tout clairement c'est un truc qui
n'existe pas assez il faut promouvoir sa
d'avantagés notamment sur des sujets
importants
cependant il est intéressant également
de noter que ce poème de la
préinscription est quelque chose d
extrêmement coûteux puisque un
laboratoire doivent s'engager à faire ça
pendant une période donnée
et si jamais il ya des échecs et faut
savoir comment est-ce qu'on gère par
exemple des échecs ou des erreurs
expérimental qui ont été faites ou plein
de petits billets qui ont été amenées
donc ça serait pas une solution finale
en tout cas il faudrait encore avoir un
peu de doute au moment d'interpréter ces
données mais surtout si tout le monde
faisait ça on serait submergé encore une
fois de donner et il y aurait encore un
biais de sélection a effectué non pas au
moment de la publication des résultats
parlent de l'écriture d'articles paris
chercheurs et ensuite de la sélection de
ce que chacun des lecteurs va être amené
à lire donc quelque part en tout cas au
niveau des lecteurs humain il y aura
très probablement encore un énorme
levier de sélection et il faudra faire
attention à ce biais de sélection et du
coup faire moins une méta analyse sur
les biais de publications potentiel là
où par contre se voir d' approche
pourrait être très intéressante c'est si
on effectue des grosses collectes de
données que l'on met ensuite dans des
fichiers informatiques qui pourra
ensuite être analysée par d'autres
algorithmes
voilà une approche qui s'est fait
énormément dans le domaine de
l'astrophysique où il ya beaucoup de
données collectées par toutes sortes de
télescopes de satellite ou de sondes
spatiales et ces données sont stockées
et partagées à travers la communauté
scientifique et n'importe qui peut faire
sa propre analyse des données sur ces
données je me sens vraiment que ce
modèle de la recherche me semble
beaucoup plus prolifiques et permettra
d'avoir des analyses de données
potentiellement bien moins biaisée que
si on passait par des biais de sélection
qui sera est notamment due à des
en sciences humaines bref il aurait
énormément plus à dire et c'est un sujet
malheureusement que je maîtrise pas non
plus tant que ça mais je pense qu'il est
super important que l'on se met tous à
davantage réfléchir à comment faire de
la meilleure science
elle espère qu'ils avaient aimé cette
vidéo la prochaine fois on verra un cas
où le prime de la fair value paraît
vraiment très très très problématique
petit teaser ça parlera notamment de
parapsychologie si vous avez aimez cette
vidéo pensez à la laquelle a commenté à
l'ats partagé par tous les abonnés pour
les futurs épisodes mes ressentis par
bordeaux et j'espère que vous serez là
la prochaine fois ce réflexe de dire ce
n'est pas scientifique est selon moi une
mauvaise habitude qui découle de la
manière dont on nous enseigne les
sciences comme si la science était une
sorte de statue grecque aux proportions
parfaites
alors qu'elle est en fait le résultat
d'un grand nombre de herman et de remise
en question et cela mais certaines
personnes dans une situation d'excès de
confiance où elles vont trouver une
sorte de valorisation sociale a cassé
tout ce qui serait pas scientifique
avec parfois un petit ricanements
méprisant ce qui n'est pas exactement
une attitude bienveillante de recherche
un bhl de la connaissance et qui va tuer
dans l'oeuf de nombreuses discussions
sur des sujets importants
ils sont cinq dates